hier ist der
Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach guten Abend
guten Abend ist denn die Pandemie nun
vorbei oder nicht
es ist richtig dass wir jetzt in einen
endemischen Zustand übergehen das heißt
die Wellen die jetzt kommen die erfassen
nicht mehr die gesamte Bevölkerung
sondern nur noch die Teile der
Bevölkerung die nicht ausreichend
geimpft sind oder Menschen die vor
Schäden haben somit ist also eine große
Welle die gesamte Bevölkerung erfassen
würde im Moment nicht zu erwarten weil
die neuen Varianten die gekommen sind
die sind nicht so anstecken und auch
nicht so gefährlich wie es vor einigen
Monaten im Labor noch aussah somit die
Situation entschärft sich etwas und
deswegen hat der Kollege Marco Buschmann
Ihnen heute diesen Brief geschrieben der
Bundesjustizminister schlägt darin vor
dass die bundesweiten
corona-schutzmaßnahmen außer Kraft
gesetzt werden sollten Sie haben ihm
noch nicht schriftlich geantwortet was
antworten Sie ihm jetzt hier
ich antworte auf keinen Fall hier
öffentlich und wir werden auch keine
öffentlichen Briefe also zitieren
sondern wir werden miteinander reden
über das ja immer gemacht haben wie das
in der Ampel Koalition auch richtig ist
wahr ist wir müssen über die Lage reden
auf der anderen Seite ist es auch
wiederum so jetzt überstürzt alle
Maßnahmen fahren zu lassen würde aus
meiner Sicht wenig Sinn machen das
verlangt ja auch Herr Drosten nicht wir
haben im Moment noch also volle
Krankenhäuser selbst die Kinder können
nicht gut versorgt werden wir haben eine
hohe Übersterblichkeit sterben noch
jeden Tag Menschen an Corona die nicht
unbedingt sterben müssen und wir haben
noch eine Bevölkerung die geschützt
werden muss insbesondere in
Krankenhäusern aber auch diejenigen die
gefährdet sind weil sie
Begleiterkrankungen haben am
Arbeitsplatz somit würden wir jetzt
alles sofort fallen lassen dann würde
natürlich die Belastung zunehmen in
einer Art und Weise wie es nicht gut
vertretbar wäre richtig ist wir können
nach dem Winter mit einer deutlich
entspannteren Situation rechnen dann hat
nicht so viel Immunität aufgebaut und
sagte auch Herr Drosten dass wir im
Sommer eine ganz andere Lage haben
werden nun haben sie selber ja schon
getwittert vor einem Jahr es wäre ein
vorgezogenes Weihnachtsgeschenk wenn
Omikron leichter verliefe und im Grunde
hatten sie recht damit haben sie ja die
Endemie also eine Krankheit wie Grippe
mit der wir leben können vorausgesagt
das ist nun eingetreten und trotzdem
höre ich raus sie wollen die Maßnahmen
auf jeden Fall weiter beibehalten sie
haben das vor einem Jahr getwittert
jetzt sagt es Herr Drosten auch wir
haben eine Endemie keine Pandemie mehr
und sie wollen trotzdem bis April weiter
festhalten an den Masken
naja wir bis April dann festhalten als
wären wir sehen aber wir sind jetzt
mitten in einer also üblen Situation die
Krankenhäuser sind total voll das
Personal ist überlastet wir haben
Schwierigkeiten Personal zu finden große
Ausfälle und wir haben eine
Übersterblichkeit seit Monaten sterben
um die 100 bis 150 Menschen mit oder an
Corona pro Tag und somit also ist eine
sehr schnelle
Öffnung hier nicht wirklich sinnvoll
klar ist die Omegon Varianten die
gekommen sind sind nicht ganz so
ansteckend wie im Labor und auch nicht
ganz so schwer verlaufen das hatte ich
auch selbst
vorhergesagt ich habe immer gesagt wenn
eine Variante kommt die auch
delta-elemente wieder hat dann würde das
hier gefährlich werden das hat sich aber
nicht ergeben somit sind wir in einer
günstigen Situation aber wir dürfen hier
nicht aus Glatteis gehen sie haben ja
gerade gesagt ob April wie es im
Infektionsschutzgesetz geschrieben ist
nun der Endpunkt sein muss oder ob viel
früher rausgehen das können wir noch
entscheiden ja wann denn wie ist denn
ihre exit Strategie manche haben ja den
Eindruck sie sind wie besessen und
wollen auf jeden Fall an den
Schutzmaßnahmen festhalten
nein das ist nicht der Fall also ich bin
froh dass die Lage sich so entwickelt
und stimme der wissenschaftlichen
Einschätzung von Herrn Drosten oder auch
anderen zu ich habe es ja selbst auch
ungefähr so vorhergesagt das ist somit
eine gute Entwicklung aber ich frage
mich ob es jetzt wirklich auf ein paar
Wochen ankommt wo wir jetzt in einer so
kritischen Situation sind ob wir nicht
warten wollen bis wir diese jetzt laufen
der winterwelle hinter uns haben da
kommt es doch jetzt nach drei Jahren
Pandemie noch ein paar Wochen nicht an
werden wir jetzt in einer ganz
besonderen Situation sind auch was das
Personal angeht also somit also wir
werden uns da bewegen ganz klar aber der
rechtliche Rahmen ist ja derzeit noch
komplett abgedeckt also wir haben ein
geltendes Infektionsschutzgesetz das
haben wir entwickelt dass die Zahlen
schlechter waren als sie jetzt sind aber
in der gleichen Größenordnung der
Minister ich habe eine frage noch zu
China da fallen ja nun fast alle
Maßnahmen zum Schutz vor Corona sogar
die quarantänepflicht für Geschäftsleute
nach Einreise könnte denn nun dort eine
gefährliche Variante entstehen die dann
zu uns zurückkommt
als wäre im Prinzip möglich dass es
etwas wovor viele Wissenschaftler Angst
haben auch in den Vereinigten Staaten
das wird intensiv untersucht wir können
nur hoffen dass es nicht so ist also
Corona wird gefährlich bleiben man kann
auch nicht das mit der Grippe
vergleichen die Grippe also ist eine
Atemwegserkrankung die
corona-erkrankungen befähigt die Gefäße
die werden also nach mehrfachen
corona-befall auch schlechter die
Immunität ganz schlechter werden
zumindest es gibt ganz kategorische
Unterschiede zwischen corona-infektionen
und Gefäß Beteiligung auf der einen
Seite und der Grippe auf der anderen
Seite wir müssen hier auch darauf achten
dass auch dauerhaft unnötige Infektionen
vermieden werden dafür brauchen wir aber
nicht mehr die Einschränkungen die wir
immer gehabt haben Minister Lauterbach
vielen Dank für das Gespräch
ich danke Ihnen
[Musik]